charles benvenuti in un nuovissimo b
in questi giorni nelle mie storie
instagram se non mi seguite ancora
fatelo subito vi ho chiesto di farmi
delle domande sul sull'amore in generale
ma più precisamente sui vostri problemi
sentimentali sui vostri problemi di
cuore e io ho provato a darvi dei
consigli ma visto che mi sono arrivati
veramente tantissimi messaggi
ho pensato perché non farci un video e
se questo video insomma piacerà farci
direttamente una serie di video nei
quali proverò di volta in volta a
rispondere a più domande possibili
partiamo subito parentesi vi avviso già
ormai chi mi segue su instagram lo sa
avrà già visto le mie risposte e
consigli non sono una che zucchero le
cose nel senso se una persona mi chiede
un consiglio mi chiede di essere sincera
con lei o con lui io sono sincera
sappiate che non sarò super bowl cina
sarò più
l'amica la migliore amica che ti fa
svegliare non mi risponde non mi cerca
la sua sorella mi ha detto che gli
piaccio
allora diciamo che magari a sua sorella
stai particolarmente simpatica e magari
vorrebbe vedervi insieme però se lui non
ti risponde non ti cerca
non la vedo poi così rosea la situazione
ricordati che se un ragazzo insomma chi
vuole chi cerca e trova nel senso non
esistono scuse in questo caso poi magari
uno può essere più timido e può essere
un po più impacciato nel approcciarsi
però se addirittura non ti risponde qui
vuol dire che tu insomma ti fai sentire
la vedo abbastanza grigia quindi il mio
consiglio è non ti focalizzare troppo su
di lui fatti la tua vita pensa te stessa
se poi lui deciderà di venirti a cercare
o comunque si farà vivo allora li valuta
perché comunque non mi sembra neanche il
carino che sia sempre tu quella che deve
fare il primo passo
mi sento con un ragazzo da tre mesi e ci
troviamo benissimo
solo che l'ex di un'amica aia allora
queste situazioni sono sempre molto
delicate per quanto ti possa piacere un
ragazzo se comunque è stato ad essi una
tua amica
prima di tutto non tel avivi bene come
se fosse uno sconosciuto seconda cosa
secondo me è sempre meglio dirlo a
questa amica gli ex sono intoccabili
però ovvio che ci sono con gli ex di cui
magari non ce ne frega niente ne sono
passati tanti anni e quindi magari una
ti dicevo era contenta per teso potente
per voi non c'è nessun problema quindi
sono sempre situazioni che bisogna
calibrare bene il mio consiglio è sempre
quello di dirlo perché comunque far le
cose di nascosto
non ha senso il tipo che mi piace mi
contatta solo per fare cose e non voglio
però mi piace ok situazione molto comune
quello che ti consiglio io è o ti fai
andare bene questa cosa perché ti piace
e ti accontenti di rapporti occasionali
oppure se vedi proprio che c'è molto
sentimento e quindi ti piacerebbe
qualcosa in più ma sai già benissimo che
tanto lui vuole quello e basta
lascia perdere perché in queste
situazioni ci si può fare veramente male
in questo periodo non mi piace nessuno è
una cosa normale assolutamente sì ci
sono periodi della vita in cui magari
non hai particolare interesse per
nessuno
quello che ti consiglio è non
focalizzati sul devo conoscere qualcuno
deve interessare per forza qualcuno se
no non so cosa fare della mia vita
perché comunque ti devi focalizzare
prima su te stessa stare bene con te
stessa poi le cose arrivano quando meno
te l'aspetti tra l'altro quindi per mia
esperienza personale quando stai lì a
dire a stasera vado a ballare
sicuramente trovo qualcuno che mi
interessa con cui mi sentirò con cui non
succede mai
quindi non vi fate castelli in aria non
pensate che dovete per forza trovare
qualcuno se non sapete cosa fare
pensate a voi stesse e siate felici e
contenti e soddisfatti di voi stessi e
vedrete che arriverà arriverà sul
cavallo bianco no forse no trappole
non ci sentiamo da tre settimane e
l'unica cosa detta da lui è stata non
voglio finirla 4 allora mi sembra di
intuire che vi siete lasciati c'è stata
una rottura e
lui appunto detto non voglio finire qua
la storia però sono tre settimane che
non vi sentite
quindi o si purtroppo orgogliosa che non
ti puoi far sentire che vorresti farti
sentire oppure lui che parla parla ma
poi fatti zero perché non voglio venir
l'acqua e poi sparisce per tre settimane
mi chiedo cosa abbia fatto in queste tre
settimane di così tanto importante per
non aver tempo di scriverti per far
sentire
ho scoperto che frequentava me e la sua
ex
non faccio nulla scrivo qualcosa o lo
prendo a pugnetto pugni
io ignorerei la situazione cioè non
farei nulla perché mi sembra di intuire
che ovviamente non ti veniva dire a te
frequenta altre ragazze quindi classica
situazione in cui lui ti fa sentire
unicatt.it flirta con te chi ti scrive
semplice per eccetera poi lo fa con akon
un'altra con altri due con altre tre
quindi innanzi tutto questo tipo one
bari niente prima cosa perché quando uno
è veramente interessato non ha bisogno
di pensare ad altre quindi è
semplicemente un cretino
2 se non dire parolacce in questo video
quindi non le dirò vabbè però avete
capito quello che pensa di questa
tipologia di uomo
quindi secondo me dub elisa meriti molto
molto di più
lascia perdere ho 19 anni e non sono mai
stata con nessuno e nemmeno mai uscita
sono tanto patetica allora patetica
assolutamente no ognuno ha i suoi tempi
ovvio che se tu stessa magari sei un pò
tv da un po introversa di chiudi in te
stessa e molto difficile che tu riesca a
conoscere delle persone quindi il mio
consiglio è quello di sciogliersi un po
di stare tranquilla rilassata
non farti parole sul fatto che non si è
mai uscita con un ragazzo non farti
paranoia seri due amiche sono gli che
parlano delle loro relazioni eccetera
eccetera tumorali ti senti la sfigata di
turno perché sfigata non sei perché
ripeto ognuno ha i suoi tempi
però mi raccomando lasciati un po andare
nel senso parla con altre persone se
magari sei un pò di vento versa cerca di
abbattere questo questo muro che magari
fa in modo che tu non riesca a
frequentare persone a uscire con persone
perché i ragazzi ovviamente le ragazze
troppo introverse che non si aprono un
po intimoriscono nel senso non sanno
come approcciare quindi se tu stessa
magari sei più a tuo agio con te stessa
allo stesso tempo un ragazzo può
sentirsi più a suo agio ad avvicinarsi a
parlare con te e perché no a uscire con
te innamorati ma troppi litigi troppa
gelosia da parte sua possessività
argomento che mi sta molto a cuore nel
senso che queste tipologie di relazioni
sono malate secondo me perché troppa
gelosia perché perché dovrebbe esserci
troppa gelosia un po di gelosia ci sta e
sana e normale
troppa gelosia ossessività e
possessività sono chiari segnali che
nella vostra relazione manca qualcosa e
probabilmente non durerà perché si può
semplicemente trasformare in qualcosa
appunto di malato e di non positivo per
entrambi il mio consiglio è cerca un
pochino di allontanarti e magari di
parlargli e dirgli apertamente che
questa situazione non ti va più bene
raramente cambiano queste situazioni nel
senso che se uno è geloso possessivo
ossessivo puoi parlargli quanto vuoi
farlo ragionare quanto vuoi ma rimarrà
così quindi quello che ti dico che
secondo me non è il ragazzo per te non
mi accontento mai
preferisco essere single piuttosto che
stare con chiunque
faccio bene allora io spenderei un
tappeto rosso per questa ragazza perché
non è che fai bene fai benissimo sono
contenta che tra tutti questi messaggi
ci sia questo messaggio di positività
che condividerò con tutti voi
perché accontentarsi non va mai bene e
spesso tante ragazze e tanti ragazzi si
accontentano perché magari non amano
stare da soli
sbagliatissimo perché non porta niente
di buono né per voi né tantomeno
poverini per i pori cristiani con cui
state quindi mi raccomando ragazzi e
ragazze all'ascolto se non siete
convinti di stare con una persona o lo
volete fare solo per non stare da soli
lasciate perdere l'amore lo percepite
nell'aria lo sentite quando siete presi
di una persona quindi o è bianco o è
nero e grigio
lasciate perdere ci siamo conosciuti un
compleanno ci siamo baciati e ora non
risponde mai
che devo fare
parte non ha ragione nel senso voglio
scrivere più evidentemente mi spiace
dirlo ma non sei stata così importante
per lui perché sennò si sarebbe fatto
sentire e non avrebbe aspettato che tu
gli scrivessi per poi non risponderti
quindi non è interessato
lo so sono cattiva mi sento cattiva di
queste cose ma è la verità
lascia perdere cioè nel senso per cosa
ci sia piaciuto questo limone al
compleanno
io guarderei oltre sono stato a pranzo
nata da un mio amico lui dice che non è
cambiato nulla
io mi sento strana e ti capisco nel
senso che ovviamente nel momento in cui
ti dichiari nei konfronti del tuo
migliore amico o di un tuo amico
qualcosa cambia nel vostro rapporto
quello che ti consiglio io e magari per
un periodo allontanati un attimino non
succede niente magari tra qualche mese
che chi è passata magari questa questa
delusione di essere stata prendo nata
potrete ritrovare il rapporto di prima
però lascia passare per scorrere qualche
mesetto secondo me non sono mai stata
fidanzate o quasi 18 anni
allora ragazzi con questa domanda devo
fare un discorso generale perché me ne
sono arrivati tantissimi messaggi di
questo tipo
lei ha 18 anni un'altra che a 15 anni
un'altra che ne atleta non c'entra
niente
l'età non c'entra niente l'età se non è
ancora arrivata la persona che insomma
li ha travolto la vita che ha fatto
battere cuore non succede nulla perché
arriverà non è che non arriva più ve lo
chiedo per favore non vi fissate perché
sono tutte fisse mentali con sta storia
del
non mi calcolerà mai più nessuno non mi
vuole nessuno
rimarrò singola vita gattara sono tutte
delle cavolate perché come vi ho già
detto prima
l'amore non ha età ai suoi tempi
ci sono persone che magari hanno trovato
il primo amore a vent'anni a 30 anni o a
50 anni e stanno benissimo nel senso
ovviamente una volta che poi trovi
d'amore non è che pensi a e puro passato
18 anni si
perché ti dimentichi tutto sei felice e
contenta quindi quello che vi consiglio
io e di amare voi stesse per prima cosa
voi stessi pensare alla vostra felicità
alle vostre passioni ai vostri amici e
quando arriverà arriverà quando meno ve
lo aspetterete sicuramente per me è
stato sempre così l'ho già detto mille
volte
se voi siete rilassati e felici e
contenti di voi stesse attirerete
attirerete con il vostro charme con la
vostra sicurezza ecco la vostra
indipendenza
ok dopo una delusione ho paura di amare
ancora sento di non esserne più in grado
che capisco so cosa vuol dire ma devi
andare veramente tranquilla perché le
delusioni d'amore le abbiamo avute tutti
e siamo sopravvissuti
ovviamente quando hai una delusione
fresca fresca
è un po più difficile magari lasciarsi
andare a sciogliersi e soprattutto a
livello appunto sentimentale o comunque
affettivo
però io credo che quando arriva la
persona giusta che tra virgolette chi fa
dimenticare le brutte esperienze che hai
avuto o le delusioni passate e subito
automatico sciogliersi e ricordati è una
follia odiare tutte le rose perché una
spina tia furto questa prima puntata
finisce qui fatemi sapere se vi piace
questa tipologia di video se vi piace ne
farà ovviamente altri come al solito
seguitemi su instagram perché insomma le
domande le prendo da lì le faccio nelle
stories primi seguitemi e iscrivetevi al
canale mi raccomando cliccando sulla
campanella vicino al tasso d'iscrizione
per ricevere una notifica tutte le volte
che esce un luogo video vi mando un
bacione e ci vediamo al prossimo video
ciao
[Musica]